Hey guys, it's Joel and today's episode will not be the Taproot Therapy Collective podcast, Discover Heal Grow. It will be an episode of this podcast that I recorded with Kike Atri, the Psyche podcast, and I wanted to share it on this channel so that I could promote him and you could check it out. If you like hearing from me, you can hear him interview me and then you can check out more on his channel at kikeatri.com and we'll link to that in the show notes so I'll go ahead and roll that interview now thank you All you children gather round, we will dance and we will whirl.
大家好，我是Joel。今天的节目不是《Taproot Therapy Collective》播客的《Discover Heal Grow》，而是我与Kike Atri录制的《Psyche》播客的一期节目。我想在这个频道分享它，以便推广他的节目，也让大家去听听看。如果你喜欢听我的内容，可以听听他对我进行的采访，然后去他的频道kikeatri.com查看更多内容。我们会在节目说明中附上链接，现在就开始播放这段采访。谢谢。所有孩子们，聚过来，我们要旋转，我们要跳舞。
We will dance to our own song, we must spin to our own world. Won't you dance with me? Stop your crying, dance with me. Feel the rhythm of my arms, don't let's cry now, dance with me. I'm going to be a good friend. I'm going to be a good friend. I'm going to be a good friend. I'm going to be a good friend. I'm going to be a good friend. I'm going to be a good friend. I'm going to be a good friend. I'm going to be a good friend. I'm going to be a good friend. I'm going to be a good friend.
我们要随着自己的歌起舞，我们必须旋转进入自己的世界。你不跟我一起跳舞吗？别哭了，跟我一起跳舞。感受我双臂的节奏，别哭了，跟我一起跳舞。我会成为一个好朋友。我会成为一个好朋友。我会成为一个好朋友。我会成为一个好朋友。我会成为一个好朋友。我会成为一个好朋友。我会成为一个好朋友。我会成为一个好朋友。我会成为一个好朋友。我会成为一个好朋友。
I'm going to be a good friend. I'm going to be a good friend. I'm going to be a good friend. I'm going to be a good friend. I'm going to be a good friend. I'm going to be a good friend. I'm going to be a good friend. I'm going to be a good friend.
我会成为一个好朋友。我会成为一个好朋友。我会成为一个好朋友。我会成为一个好朋友。我会成为一个好朋友。我会成为一个好朋友。我会成为一个好朋友。我会成为一个好朋友。
I'm going to be a good friend. I'm going to be a good friend. I'm going to be a good friend. I'm going to be a good friend. I'm going to be a good friend. I'm going to be a good friend. I'm going to be a good friend. I'm going to be a good friend. I'm going to be a good friend. I'm going to be a good friend. I'm going to be a good friend. So yeah, man, thank you so much for your time. Yeah, I really appreciate connecting. Kat, can I talk about Jung today?
我会成为一个好朋友。我会成为一个好朋友。我会成为一个好朋友。我会成为一个好朋友。我会成为一个好朋友。我会成为一个好朋友。我会成为一个好朋友。我会成为一个好朋友。我会成为一个好朋友。我会成为一个好朋友。我会成为一个好朋友。好的，伙计，非常感谢你的时间。是的，我真的很感激这次交流。Kat，我今天能谈谈荣格吗？
Yes, that's kind of what I'm hoping to get into. I'm no Jungian analyst or anything like that. I'm just someone who's been really impacted by his writings. In my own psychotherapy, I worked with someone who was kind of an in-depth Jungian. So I've been in that world for a little while and I really appreciate many aspects of it. And I actually found out about you, I guess at some level being connected to Jung.
可以，这正是我希望深入探讨的内容。我不是什么荣格分析师之类的。我只是一个深受他著作影响的人。在我自己的心理治疗中，我曾与一位深入研究荣格的人合作过。所以我进入那个领域有一段时间了，我真的很欣赏它的许多方面。其实我是在某种程度上与荣格产生联系后才了解到你的。
You have this amazing episode with David Tacey that really spoke to me. And so yeah, I was hoping to get into Jung and see how he's impacted you. Yeah, Tacey, we were lucky to have that hour or two with him. I do think he is one of the, definitely the only modern, but maybe one of the few recent people who lets Jung breathe.
你和David Tacey的那期精彩节目真的触动了我。所以，是的，我希望能深入探讨荣格，看看他是如何影响你的。是的，Tacey，我们很幸运能和他聊那一个或两个小时。我确实认为他是——绝对是唯一一位现代的，或者可能是少数几位近期能让荣格思想“呼吸”的人之一。
A lot of people put Jung into it because he's such a vast writer. He has all these ideas and then people follow the implications of those ideas over the next 30-50 years. Most people, I think, concentrate on one portion of it, or even worse, they try and make him only one element of something he wrote about and not the complexity of all of it. Because he did what I think a lot of people do, is he would get really obsessed with things that he didn't quite even know why,
很多人把荣格框住，因为他是一位著作极其宏大的作家。他有所有这些想法，然后人们在接下来的30到50年里追随这些想法的含义。我认为大多数人只关注其中的一部分，或者更糟的是，他们试图让他只成为他所写内容的某一个要素，而不是他所有思想的复杂性。因为他做了我认为很多人都会做的事，那就是他会对自己甚至不知道原因的事情变得非常着迷，
but he felt like there was something that was in there that needed to be unlocked and understood that would fit back into a larger whole. A lot of the conversations when he felt like there was something that was in there that needed to be unlocked and understood that would fit back into a larger hole You know a lot of the conversations when he is feels like well alchemy is this projection of the human psyche onto in pre scientific minds are you know Describing this change process of alchemy, you know You know he loses you one of his lovers and a couple of friends who are just like, I don't get it, man.
但他觉得里面有什么东西需要被解锁和理解，并能重新融入一个更大的整体。当他觉得里面有什么东西需要被解锁和理解，并能重新融入一个更大的整体时，你知道，很多对话……你知道，当他觉得“炼金术是人类心灵在前科学头脑中的投射”，或者你知道，在描述炼金术的这种变化过程时，你知道，他失去了他的一位爱人和几个朋友，他们只是说：“伙计，我不明白。”
I don't want to talk about, you know, reducing down to the red powder and reclaiming the self. And, you know, later, I think that fits into something, but I don't even think he knew what he was chewing on. So I think David really is one of the only writers that kind of lets him be. And maybe some of that is because he's not an analyst. He's not really in psychology. And so he's, he's kind of more of a scholar there, but I don't know. Okay.
“我不想谈论什么还原成红色粉末并找回自我。”而且，你知道，后来我认为这符合某些东西，但我甚至不认为他知道自己在咀嚼什么。所以我认为David确实是少数几个能让他保持原样的人之一。也许部分原因是由于他不是分析师。他并不真正从事心理学工作，所以他更像是一位学者，但我不知道。好吧。
Yeah. No, I, I like that. It kind of lets them breathe, you know, and it's interesting. I think, you know, quite a bit more about this than I do. You guys alluded to this in your conversation, but in his latest book, Jung and spirituality, Tacey talks about some of the American Jungians and how they're putting him in a box and maybe oversimplifying him.
是的。不，我喜欢这一点。这让他能呼吸，你知道，这很有趣。我想，你知道的这方面比我多得多。你们在对话中提到了这一点，但在他最新的书《荣格与灵性》中，Tacey谈到了一些美国荣格派学者，以及他们是如何把他关进盒子里，并可能过度简化了他。
And I didn't know if that resonated with you or if you had any thoughts on that. Well, I think what makes Tacey frustrated with the, particularly Tacey, like his take on why the American Jungians are bad is that they, and I have talked with them about that a little bit off mic, but they both sanitize Jung
我不知道这是否引起了你的共鸣，或者你对此有什么想法。嗯，我认为让Tacey对美国荣格派感到沮丧的原因是——特别是Tacey，他对为什么美国荣格派很糟糕的看法是——他们（我在麦克风外和他们聊过一点），他们既美化了荣格，
and take away kind of the real rawness of it. And at the same time, they overly literalize him. And I've encountered that. I mean, there were a lot of like, there's a lot of Jungian analysts that just kind of act like Jung is like therapy plus Jesus or for whatever their spiritual spirituality is, but there's not like a lot of maturity to it or something.
又剥夺了他那种真正的原始感。与此同时，他们又过度字面化地解读他。我遇到过这种情况。我的意思是，有很多荣格分析师表现得好像荣格就是“治疗加耶稣”，或者无论他们的灵性是什么，但其中并没有太多的成熟度。
A lot of that, I think, is maybe part of a political movement. A lot of those things too are, even though I think Jungian psychology is progressive and then it's very far-seeing, it tends to be applied conservatively because most of the time, by the time you're an analyst, you're like 75, you know? So it's not like, you know, it's not like the people
我认为这其中很多可能是一场政治运动的一部分。很多事情也是如此，尽管我认为荣格心理学是进步的，而且非常有远见，但它往往被保守地应用，因为大多数时候，当你成为一名分析师时，你已经75岁了，你知道吗？所以这不像，你知道，这不像那些
who are really carrying the fire there. And they do the same kind of silly things that everybody, you know, Freud said the narcissism of petty differences and I mean, how many institutes are there? Like every time I look at the British analytic society, like they've split again, there's like five and they hate the other one.
真正传承火种的人。他们做着和每个人一样的愚蠢事情，你知道，弗洛伊德说过“微小差异的自恋”，我的意思是，有多少个协会？每次我看到英国分析协会，就像他们又分裂了，有五个协会，而且他们互相憎恨。
You can never really tell what they actually did because there's a whole thing about, we can no longer abide the lack of transparency and demand that there be accountability and are splintering to make a new organization to whatever. It's like, what happened, man? Give me the goss, give me the hot goss. Yeah, that's a great point. So yeah, they don't get along. A lot of the silliness that goes a great point. So yeah, I mean, they don't get along, a lot of the silliness that goes along with everything.
你永远无法真正分辨他们实际上做了什么，因为有一整套关于“我们再也无法忍受缺乏透明度，要求问责，并分裂以建立一个新组织”之类的说法。就像是，伙计，发生了什么？给我八卦，给我劲爆的八卦。是的，这是一个很好的观点。所以是的，他们相处得不好。很多愚蠢的事情……这是一个很好的观点。所以是的，我的意思是，他们相处得不好，很多伴随一切的愚蠢事情。
I don't know how many actual institutes there are now, but there's been a couple of schisms as they fight. So I'm not being an analyst, I'm not in training. I think the beauty of that stuff to me is that, Jung was a thinker who made a really good map of the soul phenomenologically. Then that map is now being validated by a lot of neurology. Just like we always do,
我不知道现在实际有多少个协会，但随着他们的争斗，已经发生了几次分裂。所以，我不是分析师，我没有在接受培训。我认为这些东西的美妙之处在于，荣格是一位在现象学上为灵魂绘制了非常好的地图的思想家。然后那张地图现在正被许多神经学所验证。就像我们一直做的那样，
I mean, maybe some of that is being American, but a little bit more of it is probably being human. When we rediscover these things that somebody else pointed out, we don't always go back and give credit, and I think that happens to him a lot. Some of that is just because the history of the profession is not taught. I mean, half the time when I'm talking to
我的意思是，也许其中一部分是因为身为美国人，但更多可能仅仅是因为身为人类。当我们重新发现别人指出的这些事情时，我们并不总是回头给予认可，我认为这在他身上发生了很多次。其中一些仅仅是因为这个专业的历史没有被教授。我的意思是，有一半时间当我和
a neurologist about something that, you know, I'm meeting with him about, I'm like, yeah, you know, like the MBTI, you know, I know that that was more Mars and Briggs, but the original theories of those is that the brain basically can think in these four different ways, or eight different ways, but they're mutually exclusive. Four of them are mutually exclusive to the other one.
一位神经学家谈论我正在和他会面的事情时，我说：“是的，你知道，比如MBTI，我知道那是迈尔斯和布里格斯（Myers and Briggs）提出的，但这些理论的原始观点是，大脑基本上可以用这四种不同的方式，或者八种方式思考，但它们是互斥的。其中四种与另一种是互斥的。”
You can't be introverted at the same time you're extroverting. Acquiring information about my environment, either sensation or interpersonal information, I can't be reflecting internally at the same time. I can switch and I can be good at both of them. But we see those networks and things like QEG brain mapping and some of the fMRI stuff. Half the time when I'm talking to a neurologist about that, they're like, oh, that's interesting.
“我不能在进行外向活动的同时保持内向。在获取关于环境的信息时，无论是感觉信息还是人际信息，我不能同时进行内部反思。我可以切换，我可以两者都擅长。但我们在QEG脑成像和一些fMRI研究中看到了这些网络。有一半时间当我和神经学家谈论这个时，他们会说：‘哦，那很有趣。’”
I don't know anything about him. I thought he was like the collective unconscious guy or he was like the pseudoscience magic guy. We don't teach the history of the profession, so how could people recognize the insight 100 years later? But I think a lot of it is maybe more intentional. There's a lot of people that I complain about a lot that are big academic writers for the kind of academics that I don't really like.
“我对他一无所知。我以为他是那个‘集体潜意识’的家伙，或者他是那个伪科学魔法的家伙。”我们不教授专业的历史，所以人们怎么可能在100年后认出这些洞见呢？但我认为其中很多可能更具意图性。有很多我经常抱怨的人，他们是那种我不怎么喜欢的学术界的大学术作家。
And they'll like, it was trendy basically in the 90s to put solution focused or brief or time limited in front of every model and to just try and make the fastest version of CVT that would make the insurance company the most money. And a lot of these academics jumped on the bandwagon for their career and really made fun of the unconscious and somatic medicine and anything that was depth as being pseudoscientific. And now we're looking more at like trauma.
在90年代，在每个模型前面加上“以解决方案为中心”、“简短”或“限时”基本上是一种潮流，只是试图制造出最快版本的CBT，从而为保险公司赚最多的钱。很多这些学者为了职业生涯而随波逐流，并真正嘲笑潜意识、躯体医学和任何深度心理学，称其为伪科学。而现在我们更多地关注创伤。
And a lot of people, the industry is moving more towards looking at polyvagal responses and these kind of deeper echoes of beneath cognition. And so these same guys are basically writing something, still pretending they're right that is totally opposite of what they wrote 20, 30 years ago. And I mean, the example I give a lot of time is there's like one guy that he wrote all these things like saying that the unconscious wasn't real, the subconscious wasn't real, there was no psychishoma, there were no, you know, emotion is totally disconnected from somatics. I mean, the stuff that I think just on its face is There were no, you know, emotion is totally disconnected from somatics.
很多人，整个行业正在转向关注多迷走神经反应和这些认知之下的更深层回响。所以这些家伙基本上在写一些东西，仍然假装他们是对的，这与他们20、30年前写的东西完全相反。我的意思是，我经常举的例子是，有一个家伙，他写了所有这些东西，说潜意识不是真的，下意识不是真的，没有心理躯体，没有……你知道，情绪与躯体完全脱节。我的意思是，我认为表面上看起来……没有，你知道，情绪与躯体完全脱节。
I mean the stuff that I think just on its face is kind of crazy, you know, and then as soon as the trauma revolution comes back now He's publishing books being like oh, well, we know that there's primary secondary and tertiary levels of consciousness and the the tertiary levels are more symbolic and Biosomatic reactions to and you're like oh, you mean like a fucking unconscious. You can just say I was wrong, but they can't because they always have to be right. I don't know, that just the silliness of academia. As long as I've cited all my sources, I'm correct,
我的意思是，我认为表面上看起来有点疯狂的事情，你知道，然后一旦创伤革命回归，现在他出版书籍说：“哦，好吧，我们知道存在初级、次级和三级意识水平，三级水平更具象征意义和生物躯体反应。”你会说：“哦，你是说像该死的潜意识吗？”你可以直接说我错了，但他们不能，因为他们总是必须是对的。我不知道，学术界的这种愚蠢。只要我引用了所有的来源，我就是正确的，
even though the paper that I'm writing now says the exact opposite of the thing that I wrote 15 years ago. You know, I don't know. Like there's just a silliness to that kind of American academia, I think. And our academia is a lot more corporatized than the rest of the world's.
尽管我现在写的论文与我15年前写的东西完全相反。你知道，我不知道。就像那种美国学术界有一种愚蠢，我认为。而且我们的学术界比世界其他地方更企业化。
And so I think it is more likely to, you know, those, you're seeing the, you are seeing where that incentive structure is at odds with what would be good practice, what would be good psychology basically. I don't know if that makes sense but yeah man no that's that's like a good riff thank you for that. So I guess one of the things I wonder is how did you first get into Jung and I know he's not the only person that you think about or care about but
所以我认为它更有可能……你知道，那些，你正在看到，你正在看到那种激励结构与什么是好的实践、什么是好的心理学相矛盾的地方。我不知道这是否有意义，但是的，伙计，不，那是一个很好的即兴发挥，谢谢你。所以我猜我想知道的一件事是，你是如何第一次接触到荣格的，我知道他不是你唯一思考或关心的人，但
we're thinking about him do you remember what stage of life you were in? Maybe what was drawing you to him? Well, I remember always kind of seeing mythology and religions as being connected as a kid. And a lot of that was I was real active in the Episcopal Church in Alabama. And I've heard this from other people. The Episcopal Church tends to be like less literalist and more kind of like mystical in Alabama. Like I've heard that from Episcopalians, they're like, whoa, like this is really wild. Like y'all are using myth and like doing the Valk and the Labyrinth doing this other stuff.
当我们想到他时，你还记得你处于人生的哪个阶段吗？也许是什么吸引了你？嗯，我记得小时候总是把神话和宗教看作是相互联系的。其中很大一部分是因为我在阿拉巴马州的圣公会教堂非常活跃。我从其他人那里也听说过这一点。阿拉巴马州的圣公会教堂往往不那么字面化，更像是一种神秘主义。就像我从圣公会教徒那里听说过，他们说：“哇，这真的很狂野。你们在利用神话，在做迷宫之类的其他事情。”
And I've heard that because of anti-Semitism in the 20s, in between the 20s and the 40s, that a lot of Birmingham's Jewish community like converted basically to the Episcopal Church and it gave it this kind of more mystical, Kabbalistic character. I don't know how true that is, but I've had heard of that from a couple of people. And it definitely was true for me where we were just kind of doing myth and whatever. So I never really saw that as tension. I never had like, a lot of people are told to believe like a very literalist faith that is very dogmatic and to have a certainty and that level of certainty is always a fault. I think, you know, I'm big on that the opposite of truth
我听说因为20年代到40年代之间的反犹太主义，伯明翰的许多犹太社区基本上改信了圣公会，这赋予了它一种更神秘、卡巴拉式的特征。我不知道这有多真实，但我从几个人那里听说过。这对我来说绝对是真的，我们只是在做神话之类的东西。所以我从来没有真正把这看作是紧张关系。我从来没有像……很多人被告知要相信一种非常字面化、非常教条的信仰，并拥有一种确定性，而那种确定性水平总是一个错误。我认为，你知道，我非常赞同“真理的对立面”
is not lies, it's certainty. And that when you tell somebody, hey, you're never gonna have to change, you never have to grow, you're never gonna have to have a relationship with the transcendent. You just know everything right now. You just got to remember this for the rest of your life because you're there. You know, congratulations. When you tell that to an eight-year-old, you know, or something like I'm, I kind of think that always is wrong. And those are the people that are more likely to have like a big dark night of the soul and like lose their faith and then encounter Jung and then come back, you know, into religion. I don't really have that experience because I was raised where we talked about, you know,
不是谎言，而是确定性。当你告诉某人：“嘿，你永远不需要改变，你永远不需要成长，你永远不需要与超越性建立关系。你现在就知道一切。你只需要记住这一点，因为你已经到了。”你知道，恭喜。当你对一个八岁的孩子说这些时，你知道，或者类似的话，我有点认为这总是错的。而那些人更有可能经历像“灵魂的黑夜”那样的事情，失去信仰，然后遇到荣格，然后回到宗教中。我没有那种经历，因为我是在我们谈论
Greek mythology's relevance to Christianity in church and I didn't see them at attention for me. So when I went to school, I was always into comparative religion because my brain was always like, well, some of this stuff is cultural and that's responding to the environment. It's responding to like the unique need of like the time period you're in.
希腊神话与基督教在教堂中的相关性的环境中长大的，我没有看到它们之间存在紧张关系。所以当我上学时，我一直对比较宗教学感兴趣，因为我的大脑总是觉得：“好吧，其中一些东西是文化的，那是对环境的反应。它是在回应你所处时代背景下的独特需求。”
And then other elements of it are totally universal. So like, what are those and how do we separate those? And I love analyzing cultures and being like, well, here's how everybody reacted to the conformity of the 50s. And then like when these ideas come in, in post-World War II, you get an Eastern influence, you know, into so of course the 60s is going to do this. You know, those are reformed, those are, those are kind of a cultural analysis stuff. That's always interesting to me. But then what elements of it are universal? What elements of it repeat with
然后它的其他元素是完全普遍的。所以，那些是什么，我们如何区分它们？我喜欢分析文化，并说：“好吧，这就是每个人对50年代一致性的反应。然后当这些想法在二战后进入时，你得到了东方的影响，你知道，所以60年代当然会这样做。”你知道，那些是改革，那些是文化分析的东西。这对我来说总是很有趣。但其中哪些元素是普遍的？哪些元素会重复
these cycles or what lessons can we learn that are timeless? That was just always where I was. When I went to Swannia, I got a comparative religion major. I didn't know that Jung existed. I was reading all these people that were based on Jung, like Elated Mercia and Victor Turner, or in conversation with him in Turner's case,
这些周期，或者我们可以学到哪些永恒的教训？我一直处于那种状态。当我去Swannia时，我主修了比较宗教学。我不知道荣格的存在。我当时在读所有基于荣格的人，比如Mircea Eliade和Victor Turner，或者在Turner的案例中与他进行对话，
or some of Robert Moore's ritual and initiation things, and definitely Campbell. I remember a professor saying, you're one of the only people here with the stuff you're turning in that's doing depth psychology, but I didn't really know what depth psychology was. I was just like, okay, thanks, I'm deep. Cool. Then when I was going back to school for social work, you know, you get all this like
或者Robert Moore的一些仪式和启蒙的东西，当然还有Campbell。我记得一位教授说：“你提交的东西中，你是这里唯一一个在做深度心理学的人。”但我并不真正知道什么是深度心理学。我只是说：“好的，谢谢，我很深奥。”酷。然后当我回到学校学习社会工作时，你知道，你得到了所有这些像
CVT is the whatever. And remember like sitting in school and like waiting to like, when are we going to get to the stuff that makes sense? That's good. This all seems so surface level. It seems so silly, but you're being told it's evidence based and this is the gold standard. And then I read because I was, you know, in a job working with schizophrenia outpatient for a long time. So I was trying to prepare to go into private practice.
CBT是某种东西。我记得坐在学校里，等着：“我们什么时候才能接触到那些有意义的东西？”那很好。这一切看起来都太表面了。这看起来太愚蠢了，但你被告知这是循证的，这是黄金标准。然后我读了，因为我当时在一家精神分裂症门诊工作了很长时间。所以我试图准备进入私人诊所。
I thought that everyone else had just read the whole history of the profession, going back to Freud and seen all the schisms and knew every model. Because every time somebody was like, oh, I do DBT-based interventions and I enjoy phase two mindfulness for this whatever. I just assumed everyone knew everything and I was stupid, so I read way more than most therapists normally read. I had read 30 books on CVT and I kept being like, these seem dumb.
我以为其他人都读过整个专业的历史，追溯到弗洛伊德，看到了所有的分裂，并且了解每一个模型。因为每次有人说：“哦，我做基于DBT的干预，我喜欢这个阶段的第二阶段正念。”我只是假设每个人都知道一切，而我很笨，所以我读的书比大多数治疗师通常读的要多得多。我读了30本关于CBT的书，我一直觉得：“这些看起来很蠢。”
They seem like you're just telling people things that anybody who's curious and motivated to change would have already tried and applied before they go to therapy. Maybe, I don't know, like I couldn't do it. And so I started as a therapist when I left React, and I started trying to kind of do cognitive and behavioral interventions, and they felt weird to me, and patients were just kind of like, yeah, I mean, that seems whatever.
它们看起来就像你只是在告诉人们任何好奇且有动力改变的人在去治疗之前就已经尝试和应用过的事情。也许，我不知道，就像我做不到。所以当我离开React开始做治疗师时，我开始尝试做认知和行为干预，它们让我感觉很奇怪，而病人只是觉得：“是的，我的意思是，那看起来无所谓。”
And really just out of the terror of working with people that were very sick and wanted to get better, I just started to navigate more towards the open-ended metaphorical language of people like, you know, Ericsson and with his hypnosis. I didn't do hypnosis the way he did. I don't know that it would be ethical to do it the way that he did all the time, but those ideas overlapped quite a bit with James Hellman and his kind of imaginal and archetypal psychologies that you're turning this emotion, not into the literal image of I don't like mom or I don't like the boss at work, but imagine this as you're a hawk in a field or you know how does this image speak to you and then you're working with it and modifying it and
真的只是出于与非常生病但想好起来的人一起工作的恐惧，我开始更多地转向像Erickson和他的催眠那样开放的隐喻语言。我没有像他那样做催眠。我不知道像他那样做是否总是合乎道德的，但这些想法与James Hillman以及他那种意象和原型心理学有相当多的重叠，你把这种情绪，不是变成“我不喜欢妈妈”或“我不喜欢工作中的老板”这种字面形象，而是想象成“你是一只在田野里的鹰”，或者你知道这个形象如何对你说话，然后你与它一起工作并修改它，
then there's kind of a metacognition and freedom and a lot of that led me into somatic medicine. I was doing EMDR which I don't do anymore, but EMDR led me to brain spotting, which I feel like works a lot better with a lot less risk. And the fusion of trying to figure out what was happening and how to explain it to a patient in a way that was an empowering metaphor that was useful, just continued to kind of lead me back to Jung. I'm not a Jungian analyst, I'm not a literalist. There's a ton of people that will tell me,
然后有一种元认知和自由，其中很多引导我进入了躯体医学。我当时在做EMDR，我现在不做了，但EMDR引导我走向了脑点（Brainspotting），我觉得它效果更好，风险更小。试图弄清楚发生了什么，以及如何以一种有用的赋能隐喻向病人解释它的融合，只是继续引导我回到荣格。我不是荣格分析师，我不是字面主义者。有很多人会告诉我，
well, you can't say that about Carl Jung because this thing contradicts something that he wrote on page 100 or whatever. And a lot of times when I look those things up, I think that's overly semantic. That's not really how I think. So I'm not, I don't want to over-represent, you know, my credentials or my take on him, but it is something that has continued to be the best lens for incredibly complex systems of cognition. I think he probably drew the best metaphorical map that still contains modern psych in a way that is not reductive. Whereas sometimes we're overly reductive and sometimes we say things about cognition that are just wrong. Like in Freud's case, that everything goes back to sexuality or natural selection, I think is just not true.
“好吧，你不能那样说卡尔·荣格，因为这件事与他在第100页写的东西相矛盾。”等等。很多时候当我查阅这些东西时，我认为那过于语义化了。那并不是我思考的方式。所以我不想过度代表我的资历或我对他的看法，但它确实继续成为理解极其复杂的认知系统的最佳视角。我认为他可能绘制了最好的隐喻地图，仍然以一种非还原论的方式包含了现代心理学。而有时我们过于还原论，有时我们对认知的描述是错误的。比如在弗洛伊德的案例中，我认为一切都归结于性或自然选择是不正确的。
Okay. Man, Joel, there's many threads in there that I want to follow. Maybe real quick and I'll try to remember all of them. Can you just define what brain spotting is? I know you've mentioned that to me a couple of times and that's something I'm not familiar with. Yeah, maybe go there. Brain spotting is an eye position therapy. Brain spotting came from EMDR, David Grand, who was the founder.
好的。伙计，Joel，那里有很多我想跟进的线索。也许很快，我会试着记住所有这些。你能定义一下什么是脑点（Brainspotting）吗？我知道你对我提过几次，那是我不熟悉的东西。是的，也许从那里开始。脑点是一种眼位疗法。脑点源于EMDR，创始人是David Grand。
He was a brain spotting therapist, or he was an EMDR therapist. And he actually was an EMDR therapist under the founder of EMDR, Shapiro. And I think Shapiro was dead by the time he came up with brain spotting, I believe, but I'm not positive. But EMDR is very like restrictive. It's the one that your eyes move back and forth. Like you follow the clinician's fingers and they kind of have the photos off a hand, you know?
他是一位脑点治疗师，或者他是一位EMDR治疗师。他实际上是在EMDR创始人Shapiro手下的EMDR治疗师。我想在他提出脑点时Shapiro已经去世了，我相信，但我不能确定。但EMDR非常……限制性。就是那种你的眼睛来回移动的。就像你跟随临床医生的手指，他们有一种手势，你知道吗？
Yeah. But the thing about EMDR is, I mean Shapiro made completely reasonable guesses about how the brain worked. We just have 40 more years in neuroscience. And that whole thing that you're inducing some kind of like bicameral stimulation by moving the eyes back and forth just isn't right.
是的。但关于EMDR的事情是，我的意思是Shapiro对大脑的工作方式做出了完全合理的猜测。我们只是在神经科学领域多了40年的研究。而那种通过眼睛来回移动来诱导某种双侧刺激的说法是不正确的。
It does work a lot of the time, but it works a different way. I feel like brain spotting works with less risk. And so brain spotting is static eye position. Sometimes one eye is covered, sometimes both eyes are open, but you're looking for spots that are more activating. And a lot of times if there's a theta wave that is present, both eyes are open, but you're looking for spots that are more activating. And a lot of times, if there's a theta wave that is present, if the brain is kind of doing what we would maybe call
它在很多时候确实有效，但它以不同的方式起作用。我觉得脑点在风险更小的情况下起作用。所以脑点是静态眼位。有时一只眼睛被遮住，有时双眼睁开，但你在寻找更具激活性的点。很多时候，如果存在θ波，双眼睁开，但你在寻找更具激活性的点。很多时候，如果存在θ波，如果大脑正在做我们可能称之为
memory reconsolidation in some schools, eye position is relevant to the type of memory that we access and the way that we access it. Erickson said that in the 70s, and then everyone kind of forgot about it. And newer QEG and fMRI research is validating that that's true in humans and bonobos. And it's not that eye position is relevant 100% of the time
某些流派中的“记忆重组”，眼位与我们访问的记忆类型以及我们访问它的方式有关。Erickson在70年代说过这一点，然后每个人都把它忘了。而较新的QEG和fMRI研究正在验证这在人类和倭黑猩猩身上是真实的。并不是说眼位在100%的时间里都是相关的，
but there are ways to use it in therapy that control the way that we think and help us kind of decompartmentalize trauma. And I am a pretty skeptical about anything. Like I want a really strong result. EMDR works for about 30% of people. And so research never really figured out what to do with it because they would average the 30 and the 70 I want a really strong result. EMDR works for about 30% of people and so research never really figured out what to do with it because they would average
但在治疗中有使用它的方法，可以控制我们的思考方式，并帮助我们分解创伤。我对任何事情都相当怀疑。我想要一个非常强有力的结果。EMDR对大约30%的人有效。所以研究从未真正弄清楚该怎么处理它，因为他们会平均30%和70%……我想要一个非常强有力的结果。EMDR对大约30%的人有效，所以研究从未真正弄清楚该怎么处理它，因为他们会平均
the 30 and the 70 and be like well this is either slightly more effective or slightly less effective than nothing so it might be a placebo effect and when I started doing it I immediately was like okay this does something for some people that is not a placebo like that is a dramatic you know but it also doesn't do it for a lot of people and it also doesn't do it for a lot of people. And it also doesn't work for the reasons that they say it works. It isn't that you get 15 movements instead of 14. It isn't because, I mean, it's just a lot of the things built into EMDR are not right. And with brain spotting, it gave me the ability to help about 80% of people, even
30%和70%，并说：“好吧，这要么比什么都不做稍微有效一点，要么稍微无效一点，所以它可能是一种安慰剂效应。”当我开始做它时，我立刻觉得：“好吧，这对某些人确实有作用，这不是安慰剂，那是一个戏剧性的……你知道。”但它对很多人也没有作用。而且它对很多人也没有作用。而且它不起作用的原因也不是他们所说的那样。并不是因为你做了15次移动而不是14次。并不是因为……我的意思是，EMDR中内置的很多东西都是不对的。而通过脑点，它让我能够帮助大约80%的人，甚至
people who weren't coming in saying that they had PTSD or didn't have a significant like a, you know, trauma history. There was still some kind of icky place that they avoided emotionally. And so you, you use a pointer to find an eye position. That eye position becomes very activating. Unlike EMDR, most of the processing's not in the room. You're opening a box and then over the next five, six hours, you know, up to 12, 24 hours, people re-experience these really strong kind of childhood reactions that are emotional or have to do with an intense traumatic experience. Usually you're very tired. Usually your dreams are bizarre. And so all the things that would happen in therapy normally like, you know, somatics
那些没有说他们有PTSD或没有重大创伤史的人。仍然有一些他们在情感上回避的讨厌的地方。所以你使用指针来寻找一个眼位。那个眼位变得非常具有激活性。与EMDR不同，大部分处理过程不在房间里。你打开一个盒子，然后在接下来的五、六个小时，你知道，长达12、24小时，人们重新体验这些非常强烈的童年反应，这些反应是情绪化的，或者与强烈的创伤经历有关。通常你非常累。通常你的梦很离奇。所以所有在治疗中通常会发生的事情，比如躯体
being tied to emotion and dreams kicking up to give you more of kind of a metaphor thing, they happen in like 12 hours instead of like five, six months. And so they're much more noticeable. And for things like dissociative disorders, it's very powerful. It doesn't work for everybody. I think the people that think they have a silver bullet that works for everyone, that's when you're kind of turning into a crank, you got to be flexible. But it does work for a lot, a lot of people.
与情绪挂钩，梦境激起以给你更多隐喻性的东西，它们在12小时内发生，而不是五、六个月。所以它们更明显。对于像解离性障碍这样的事情，它非常强大。它并不对每个人都有效。我认为那些认为自己拥有对每个人都有效的“银弹”的人，那就是你有点变成怪人了，你必须灵活。但它确实对很多人、很多人有效。
Emotional transformation therapy is another weird one that I never would have believed I would end up in that world. I wouldn't believe that it worked until I could reproduce it over and over and over again totally consistently with people who did not know what was supposed to happen having the same consistent effect. But ETT is a couple modules and a couple devices, but it uses color and light and light direction against the pupil and flicker rate and it reproduces. You can reproduce four million different colors very accurately, flicker rates very precisely and it also tricks
情绪转化疗法（ETT）是另一个奇怪的疗法，我以前绝不会相信我会进入那个世界。我不会相信它有效，直到我能一次又一次地完全一致地重现它，与那些不知道会发生什么的人一起，产生同样一致的效果。但ETT是几个模块和几个设备，但它使用颜色、光线、光线对瞳孔的方向和闪烁频率，它重现了……你可以非常准确地重现四百万种不同的颜色，非常精确的闪烁频率，它也欺骗了
the brain into having this fugue state where things are experienced. Then over the next couple of days, they're available for therapy and really effective. That's what those are and I think again, those validate a lot of Jung's phenomenology and with methods you didn't have access to at the time. Fascinating, man. I appreciate your confidence and just how articulate you are
大脑进入这种神游状态，事情被体验到。然后在接下来的几天里，它们可用于治疗，而且非常有效。这就是那些东西，我认为它们再次验证了荣格的许多现象学，并使用了他当时无法获得的方法。太迷人了，伙计。我欣赏你的自信以及你对所有这些东西的表达能力。
with all that stuff. It's really cool. Now, another thread that you kind of threw out there was, man, I've never brought Milton Erickson into conversation with James Hillman. Yeah. Tell me a little bit more of your thoughts on that, of how you bring those two figures together,
这真的很酷。现在，你抛出的另一个线索是，伙计，我从来没有把Milton Erickson和James Hillman联系在一起。是的。多告诉我一些你的想法，关于你是如何将这两个人物结合在一起的，
because those are two that I really appreciate, but I've never really put them together. Yeah, I mean, I think the three line there. Well, one, I don't think Hillman ever finishes his psychology. I think he kind of gets angry at the speed. I think Hillman gets very angry at like, the way that the institutes are very literal. He wants to blow that up. He wants it to be more shamanic. He wants it to be more spiritual, but he doesn't quite get the language. Archetypal psychology, when you read it, it's not done.
因为这两个人我都很欣赏，但我从来没有真正把他们放在一起。是的，我的意思是，我认为那里的三条线。嗯，第一，我不认为Hillman完成了他的心理学。我认为他有点对速度感到愤怒。我认为Hillman对那些协会非常字面化的方式感到非常愤怒。他想炸掉它。他想让它更具萨满色彩。他想让它更具灵性，但他没有完全掌握那种语言。原型心理学，当你读它时，它没有完成。
It's like you made a map back to psychosis, but you need something else. You need a return. When I talked to his biographer, Dick Russell, that was one of the things he'd said was that he felt like at that point, Hillman was very mad at Jung as kind of a failure of a father. And when he read the Red Book, when the Red Book was released, he felt like Hillman understood him better and forgave him.
就像你绘制了一张回到精神病的地图，但你需要别的东西。你需要一个回归。当我与他的传记作者Dick Russell交谈时，他说的一件事是，他觉得在那一点上，Hillman对荣格作为父亲的失败感到非常愤怒。而当他读到《红书》，当《红书》发布时，他觉得Hillman更好地理解了他并原谅了他。
And that a lot of that was what he was sort of looking for with archetypal psychology. So I think maybe when we read Hillman, we should understand those works as unfinished or that process as unfinished because he was basically sort of writing his red book, like when he's in that period. And the thing with Ericsson that I think that overlaps there
而且这其中很多就是他用原型心理学所寻找的东西。所以我认为也许当我们读Hillman时，我们应该理解那些作品是未完成的，或者那个过程是未完成的，因为他基本上是在写他的《红书》，就像他在那个时期一样。而我认为Erickson与此重叠的地方
is what he was doing was saying, we don't have to treat this image, like this literal image that this happened to you, turn that emotion into an energy that is somatic and metaphorical. And then let's, once we have this image that represents that thing to you, turn that emotion into an energy that is somatic and metaphorical. And then once we have this image that represents that thing to you, you're turning it into a symbol, just like a ritual. Let's start to modify the image so that you have more power over it.
是他所做的是说：“我们不必对待这个形象，就像这发生在你身上的字面形象一样，把那种情绪变成一种躯体和隐喻的能量。然后让我们，一旦我们有了这个代表那件事的形象……把那种情绪变成一种躯体和隐喻的能量。然后一旦我们有了这个代表那件事的形象，你就在把它变成一个符号，就像一个仪式。让我们开始修改这个形象，这样你就能对它有更多的控制力。”
And then that will give you, because the event that happened is not the thing. It's that you're afraid to feel that way again. You're unconsciously avoiding going back into those places. So if it's that mom made you feel small, let's deal with size, let's deal with scale, let's have a predator that's soaring above you and big and that you're small or if it's trapped, let's turn this into a room.
然后那会给你，因为发生的事件不是那件事。而是你害怕再次有那种感觉。你在潜意识里避免回到那些地方。所以如果是因为妈妈让你感到渺小，让我们处理大小，让我们处理规模，让我们有一个在你上方翱翔的捕食者，它是巨大的，而你是渺小的；或者如果是被困住了，让我们把它变成一个房间。
And that's what Erickson did with hypnosis. And it's largely, I think why Ericksonian hypnosis died off is that he was so intuitive and just nobody else was able to died off is that he was so intuitive and just nobody else was able to do it the way he was. I mean, he had students that really respected him, but even they didn't have the same skills that he did. And there's so much that you need to do that kind of intuitive
这就是Erickson用催眠所做的。而且我认为Ericksonian催眠之所以消亡，很大程度上是因为他太直觉了，而其他人根本无法像他那样做。我的意思是，他有非常尊重他的学生，但即使他们也没有他那样的技能。你需要做那种直觉的
hypnosis that you can't teach. You know, and so he was successful, but it kind of went away just because, you know, what are the odds that you're going to find enough people that you can teach how to do that? And, you know, Hillman was also, you know, pretty intuitive guy, but they're both sort of turning this event or emotional, they're listening to what the emotional narrative is and then turning that into sort of a metaphor disconnected with it that you can work with, you know. Got it. Oh, that's really good, man.
催眠的东西太多了，你无法教。你知道，所以他是成功的，但它消失了，只是因为，你知道，你找到足够多的人来教他们如何做那件事的几率是多少？而且，你知道，Hillman也是一个相当直觉的人，但他们都在某种程度上把这个事件或情绪，他们在倾听情绪叙事是什么，然后把它变成一种与之脱节的隐喻，你可以用它来工作，你知道。明白了。哦，那真的很好，伙计。
I have not made those connections, but that's something I want to think more about. Yeah, bringing those two together. That's awesome. That's why. Yeah, please go ahead. Go ahead. Well, no, what I was going to say, what I was going to ask, you know, hitting on Hillman for a second too, I'm always curious how practitioners who are into this stuff, maybe navigate that
我还没有建立那些联系，但那是我想要更多思考的事情。是的，把这两个人结合在一起。那太棒了。这就是为什么。是的，请继续。继续。嗯，不，我要说的是，我要问的是，（提到Hillman一秒钟），我总是很好奇从事这些东西的从业者，也许是如何驾驭那种
tension of like a polytheistic versus monotheistic psychology. Do you see that as a dualism that we have to maintain? Do you find a third way? You're frustrated with the whole model. I think when you turn, I'm one of those people that never was into philosophy because you could diagram an argument and be like, well, here are the six steps to disprove Plato's theory of forms from the parmenides. I just personally hate that philosophy. I think it's not the point. Just going back to comparative religion,
多神论与一神论心理学之间的紧张关系。你认为那是一种我们必须维持的二元论吗？你找到了第三条路吗？你对整个模型感到沮丧。我认为当你转向……我是一个从来不沉迷于哲学的人，因为你可以画出一个论点图，并说：“好吧，这里有六个步骤来反驳柏拉图的《巴门尼德篇》中的形式理论。”我个人讨厌那种哲学。我认为那不是重点。回到比较宗教学，
you're saying monotheistic versus apoliteistic psychology. Look at the tensions inherent in a monotheistic and apoliteistic religion. Does Catholicism look that different from Hinduism? When you're saying, I need to access this one little piece of the divine and that piece of in a polytheistic religion, you know? Does Catholicism look that different from Hinduism? When you're saying, I need to access this one little piece of the divine and that piece of the divine is, you know,
你说的是一神论与多神论心理学。看看一神论和多神论宗教中固有的紧张关系。天主教看起来和印度教有那么大不同吗？当你说是“我需要访问神圣的一小部分，而那一部分……”在多神论宗教中，你知道吗？天主教看起来和印度教有那么大不同吗？当你说是“我需要访问神圣的一小部分，而那一部分神圣是……”
a child in a hopeless case in a hospital. So I'm gonna go to St. Jude and ask him to act as intermediary to God. When you're saying, okay, well in India, you know, elephants are used as construction equipment. They move obstacles. So I need an obstacle removed from my life. And the part of the divine, the part of change
医院里一个绝望案例中的孩子。所以我要求助于圣犹大，让他充当上帝的中介。当你说是“好吧，在印度，你知道，大象被用作建筑设备。它们移动障碍物。”所以我需要从我的生活中移除一个障碍。而神圣的一部分，我需要访问的改变的一部分
that I need to access is Ganesha, the elephant god who removes obstacles. So I'm gonna go to him and ask him to intercede, you know, with Vishnu for me. Like, how different are those things? You know what I mean? So I'm kind of of the camp that those distinctions are useful when we need to paint broadly,
是象神Ganesha，那个移除障碍的大象神。所以我要求助于他，让他为我向毗湿奴代求。我的意思是，这些事情有多大不同？你知道我的意思吗？所以我属于那种认为这些区别在我们需要广泛描绘时是有用的阵营。
but that you're always painting broadly and that when you dig into a lot of these things, they don't quite exist, if that makes sense. Yeah, no, it does. Even Buddhism, people talk about, well, Buddhism has no self or whatever. What does it really mean to have a religious system where there is no self? You're using self-based metaphors to talk about how to get, a lot of these things... And then Theravada Buddhism maybe is essentially atheism and very mystical,
但你总是泛泛而谈，当你深入挖掘这些事物时，它们并不完全存在，如果这说得通的话。是的，确实如此。即使是佛教，人们也会说，嗯，佛教没有自我之类的。拥有一个没有自我的宗教体系到底意味着什么？你正在使用基于自我的隐喻来谈论如何获得，很多这些东西……然后上座部佛教也许本质上是无神论的，而且非常神秘，
but in Mahayana Buddhism you have like gods and bodhisattvas that you're encountering who are spiritual entities that are guiding you. It becomes very polytheistic and religious again. Like when you believe in angels that are coming to you and talking to you, how is that the Theravada atheism consciousness is an illusion? I mean, these things, you know, they're big and they're complicated. And a lot of people don't think about the tensions and stuff they believe, you know, and that's doubly true in religion, You know, it's a symbolic language.
但在大乘佛教中，你有神灵和菩萨，你遇到的是引导你的精神实体。它又变得非常多神论和宗教化了。就像当你相信有天使来到你身边并与你交谈时，这怎么会是上座部佛教的“意识是一种幻觉”的无神论呢？我的意思是，这些事情，你知道，它们很大，很复杂。很多人并没有思考他们所相信的那些张力之类的东西，你知道，这在宗教中加倍适用，你知道，这是一种象征性的语言。
I think. Going back to Tacey real quick, as I read his last book and have been thinking about a couple other authors, they're wanting to highlight maybe the disenchantment that we're in, kind of in the modern world and our society. Does any of that kind of stuff resonate with you? Do you have any thoughts on that? Are you even interested in that whole thing? Yeah, I think that a lot of metamodern philosophers, like people like Jurgen Habermas, who are talking about the post-secular sacred, or people like Peter Slatterdeke that are writing
我想。回到泰西（Tacey）的话题，当我读他最后一本书并思考其他几位作者时，他们想要强调我们所处的某种幻灭感，在现代世界和我们的社会中。这些东西中有哪一部分能引起你的共鸣吗？你对此有什么想法吗？你甚至对整个事情感兴趣吗？是的，我认为许多超现代哲学家，比如像尤尔根·哈贝马斯（Jurgen Habermas）这样谈论后世俗神圣的人，或者像彼得·斯洛特戴克（Peter Slatterdeke）这样写作的人
anthropotechnics, they're talking about the same thing as the depth schools of psychology that are saying that there's this this era where we have turned to the world so empirical, so literal, so objective, that we're not noticing how much we're projecting religion on it. And that is something that I talk about a lot, I write about a lot, and it probably is one of the more controversial things I say because a lot of people, well I don't know why, but a lot of people get mad at me and say, no, no, no, that can't be right because of this. Or they think that I'm basically either defending religion or attacking it, which is strange
人类技术（anthropotechnics），他们谈论的与深度心理学流派谈论的是同一件事，即我们已经转向了一个如此经验主义、如此字面化、如此客观的世界，以至于我们没有注意到我们正在将多少宗教投射到它上面。这是我经常谈论、经常写作的事情，它可能是我所说的更具争议的事情之一，因为很多人，嗯，我不知道为什么，但很多人对我感到生气，说，不，不，不，那不可能是对的，因为这个。或者他们认为我基本上是在捍卫宗教或攻击它，这很奇怪
because I'm not doing either. But it's some kind of noticing how religion is active in their own life and in culture in a way that I don't think certain people wanna do. I mean, and so one example of that would be, well, I don't know, maybe I'm not answering what you're asking, you know, but I think we- No, no, but I like where you're going, please.
因为我两者都没做。但这是一种注意到宗教如何在他们自己的生活和文化中以一种我认为某些人不想做的方式活跃起来。我的意思是，举个例子，嗯，我不知道，也许我没有回答你问的问题，你知道，但我认为我们——不，不，但我喜欢你的方向，请继续。
Well, that diagram in Edward Edinger's Ego and Archetype, where he's talking about, you know, when you have the USSR existing and functioning and its secular religion, its communism, or when you have, you know, America and the white picket fence and the lost culture of the suburbs, that there's this containing system of metaphors that everyone's symbolism is operating in. But then when you take that away, you have, and I think he's probably quoting T.S. Eliot when he says, the heap of broken images like in that diagram I'm imagining,
嗯，爱德华·埃丁格（Edward Edinger）在《自我与原型》（Ego and Archetype）中的那张图表，他谈到，你知道，当苏联存在并运作时，它的世俗宗教，它的共产主义，或者当你拥有，你知道，美国和白色栅栏以及郊区失落的文化时，每个人象征意义都在其中运作的隐喻包含系统。但当你把它拿走时，你就会有，而且我认为他可能在引用T.S.艾略特（T.S. Eliot）的话，当他说，像我想象的那张图表里那堆破碎的图像，
probably a right wasteland reference. When he says that central container breaks down, all those archetypes are experienced directly and it's too much. You get a culture that looks like schizophrenia. Which I think you see that things like on January 6, if you talk to the people who are storming the Capitol, they don't believe a consistent thing. Some of them are talking about aliens,
可能是一个荒原（Wasteland）的引用。当他说那个核心容器破裂时，所有那些原型都被直接体验到了，这太多了。你会得到一种看起来像精神分裂症的文化。我认为你在1月6日之类的事情上看到了这一点，如果你和那些冲击国会大厦的人交谈，他们并不相信一致的东西。他们中的一些人在谈论外星人，
some of them are talking about the 5G cell phone towers making the flu. Some of them are talking about things that are very political. Some of them are talking about things that are very spiritual. Some of them are talking about things that are very spiritual. But it's not like, I mean, that's not the same as like the Cuban revolution where people were like, we don't want gambling machines, we're going to make political change. It looks more like a religious movement than a political one. And you see things like that when empires start to decline or when people feel like the government doesn't reflect their ego anymore, then you get mass religious movements and cults all the time. I talked about that a little bit with Matt Hungelshelling in
他们中的一些人在谈论5G手机信号塔制造流感。他们中的一些人在谈论非常政治化的事情。他们中的一些人在谈论非常精神层面的事情。他们中的一些人在谈论非常精神层面的事情。但这不像，我的意思是，这和古巴革命不一样，当时人们说，我们不想要赌博机，我们要进行政治变革。它看起来更像是一场宗教运动，而不是一场政治运动。当你看到帝国开始衰落，或者当人们觉得政府不再反映他们的自我时，你就会一直看到大规模的宗教运动和邪教。我和马特·亨格谢林（Matt Hungelshelling）谈过一点
his book that is coming out on May 20th, The Ghost Lab that's essentially about him realizing that some of these ghost hunters were doing pretty good therapy when he started to meet them on themselves and others in a system where the healthcare system is kind of failing. So I do think there's this element of religion coming back when we become overly literal. David Tacey writes a little bit in Jung in the New Age and the post-secular sacred and in Edge of the Sacred in those books and some of his other work, he talks about this idea that Jung saw there being three ages.
他将于5月20日出版的书《幽灵实验室》（The Ghost Lab），本质上是关于他意识到当他在医疗体系有点失败的系统中遇到这些捉鬼人时，他们正在对自己和他人进行相当不错的治疗。所以我确实认为，当我们变得过于字面化时，宗教回归的因素就存在了。大卫·泰西（David Tacey）在《荣格与新时代》（Jung in the New Age）和《后世俗神圣》（The post-secular sacred）以及《神圣的边缘》（Edge of the Sacred）这些书中写了一些，以及他的一些其他作品，他谈到了荣格认为有三个时代的观点。
Like he thought the first age was going to be mythological, and the Bronze Age stuff and the religion. Then that stuff would be dethroned and society would move more to a scientific enlightenment values of more freedom for more people, objectivity, logic, reason. But that that would fail and that you would go back to a thing when they say, science is great and good and these are the things that we can be objective about. But there is this inherent subjective experience and we need to just go ahead and
就像他认为第一个时代将是神话般的，青铜时代的东西和宗教。然后那些东西会被废黜，社会将更多地转向科学启蒙价值观，即为更多人提供更多自由、客观性、逻辑、理性。但那会失败，你会回到一个他们说，科学是伟大而美好的，这些是我们能够客观对待的事情的时代。但存在这种内在的主观体验，我们需要继续并
admit the self-evidential nature of things like that the Earth is sacred and we have to take care of it. I can't tell you with a spreadsheet, I can't explain to BlackRock why we don't need to light the planet on fire. But I think that it is self-evident that that is a bad idea, that we shouldn't end the world just to go ahead and make a little bit of profit for capitalism over
承认事物的自明性，比如地球是神圣的，我们必须照顾它。我无法用电子表格告诉你，我无法向贝莱德（BlackRock）解释为什么我们不需要点燃地球。但我认为，不应该为了在10年、100年内，无论我们得到多久，为资本主义赚取一点利润而毁灭世界，这本身就是不言而喻的坏主意。
a 10-year, 100-year period, however long we get. Jung was seeing those tensions, a lot of them through impending nuclear age and some things. And so I think that's what Tacey is analyzing when he's saying that Jung saw this kind of third age that Tacey calls a post-secular sacred, where we would come to this idea that we can hold religion and logic simultaneously. We don't have to be literal about religion, but we also don't have to try and make science a religion because it's not and it can't be. It fails to be. I'm thinking right now of the people like some of the people that are the weirder ones
荣格看到了这些张力，很多是通过即将到来的核时代和一些事情。所以我认为这就是泰西在分析时所说的，荣格看到了这种泰西称之为后世俗神圣的第三个时代，我们将达到这样一种观念，即我们可以同时持有宗教和逻辑。我们不必对宗教采取字面理解，但我们也不必试图让科学成为一种宗教，因为它不是，也不可能是。它做不到。我现在想到像一些更奇怪的人
making these like LLMs and AI right now. Where I mean there's one guy like who has said multiple times I'm a Buddhist so consciousness is an illusion and there is no God and that we just need to realize that like we're atoms bumping up against each other and here that to span the illusion of consciousness. But if we can get enough Nvidia cores together and comp time, then the God is going to come out of the LLM. And you're like, what are you talking about? Like you're saying you're an atheist and consciousness is an illusion, but you're going to make God with a video card. Like what are you saying? That's wild. You know, and I'm not making fun of somebody for being religious or being an atheist and consciousness is an illusion, but you're going to make God with a video card? Like, what are you saying? That's wild.
现在正在制造这些大语言模型（LLM）和人工智能的人。我的意思是有一个人多次说过，我是佛教徒，所以意识是一种幻觉，没有上帝，我们只需要意识到我们只是原子相互碰撞，在这里跨越意识的幻觉。但如果我们能把足够的英伟达核心和计算时间放在一起，那么上帝就会从大语言模型中出来。你会说，你在说什么？就像你说你是无神论者，意识是一种幻觉，但你要用显卡制造上帝。就像你在说什么？这太疯狂了。你知道，我不是在取笑某人是宗教信徒或无神论者，意识是一种幻觉，但你要用显卡制造上帝？就像，你在说什么？这太疯狂了。
You know, and I'm not making fun of somebody for being religious or being an atheist. I'm just saying like that statement is so, there is so much there, you know, that is scary, that is confusing. And these are some of the most wealthy and powerful people that exist right now, you know. Yeah. I don't know if that is relevant, but those are the kind of ideas I think associated with that,
你知道，我不是在取笑某人是宗教信徒或无神论者。我只是说那句话太，那里有很多东西，你知道，这很可怕，这很令人困惑。而这些人是目前存在的最富有、最有权势的人，你知道。是的。我不知道这是否相关，但这些是我认为与此相关的想法，
if you want to apply them to the moment we're in. There's plenty of other examples when empires like Rome fall from the path. Yeah. I think that's a scary but good point. Do you make anything of what some people want to call the Jung-Post-Jungian split? I mean, I know at one level it is a thing, but I've had some people describe it as maybe too exaggerated or maybe there wasn't that deep of a division between Jung and Hillman and some of the others? Yeah, if I say post Jungian as like shorthand, I will have people to get mad at me.
如果你想把它们应用到我们所处的时刻。当像罗马这样的帝国偏离轨道时，还有很多其他的例子。是的。我认为这是一个可怕但很好的观点。你对有些人想称之为“荣格-后荣格分裂”的事情有什么看法吗？我的意思是，我知道在某种程度上它确实存在，但我有一些人将其描述为可能被夸大了，或者荣格和希尔曼（Hillman）以及其他人之间可能没有那么深刻的分歧？是的，如果我把“后荣格”作为速记，我会让人对我生气。
So there are people to react to that because they don't wanna see themselves as separate from him or something. I'm just kind of using it practically. Like obviously the psychology's evolved because this person was so broad and they dealt with the implications. They implied so much, They didn't have time to
所以有人会对那个做出反应，因为他们不想把自己看作是与他分开的，或者其他什么。我只是在实际地使用它。显然心理学已经进化了，因为这个人太广泛了，他们处理了这些含义。他们暗示了太多，他们没有时间
resolve all those implications. And so that was kind of the job of the Edingers and the von Franzes and the people that took different aspects that spoke to them and ran with them. And so there is something, what I would say is post Jungian would be something like Hillman saying, well, the anima and the animus have to exist in everybody. It's not that men have an anima, women have an animus. It's that these are both archetypes that everybody has. If they're archetypes, then both genders have them. I think that is a place where Hillman
解决所有这些含义。所以这有点像埃丁格（Edingers）和冯·弗朗茨（von Franzes）以及那些采取了对他们说话并随之运行的不同方面的人的工作。所以有一些东西，我会说后荣格的东西会像希尔曼说的那样，嗯，阿尼玛（anima）和阿尼姆斯（animus）必须存在于每个人身上。并不是说男人有阿尼玛，女人有阿尼姆斯。而是这些都是每个人都有的原型。如果它们是原型，那么两种性别都有它们。我认为这是希尔曼的一个地方
generally was post-Union. I think there's places where he repackaged Jung or reduced him and then called himself post-Union where he was not right, just because he was kind of angry at a father figure. And I think he moves past that by the end of his life. But with the schools, I think the things that are post-Union are things like
通常是后荣格的。我认为有些地方他重新包装了荣格或贬低了他，然后称自己为后荣格，而他是不对的，仅仅是因为他有点生父亲形象的气。我认为他在生命结束时超越了这一点。但对于这些流派，我认为后荣格的东西是像
Sidron Halston doing voice dialogue therapy, or Arnie Mandel doing process-oriented therapy. Because there is a trend in the 70s through the 90s where the Union analysts in the institutes became so literalist and so entrenched in sort of concretizing that what I think is a more intuitive psychology than they were letting it be. A lot of people left and they started new models because they said we want the experientialness of Fritz Perls and we want the somatics of the trauma people. A lot of that's in California and you have
西德隆·哈尔斯顿（Sidron Halston）进行语音对话治疗，或者阿尼·曼德尔（Arnie Mandel）进行过程导向治疗。因为在70年代到90年代有一种趋势，研究所里的荣格分析师变得如此字面主义，并如此根深蒂固地具体化，以至于我认为这是一种比他们所允许的更直观的心理学。很多人离开了，他们开始了新的模式，因为他们说我们想要弗里茨·皮尔斯（Fritz Perls）的体验感，我们想要创伤人群的躯体学。很多都在加利福尼亚，你有
Jungian analysts that are watching people do yoga on the beach and making these connections. People like the Stones, which we've talked to Tamar Stone, Hal's daughter on our podcast, and also people like Arnie Mendel, who do process-oriented therapy, which is a really interesting book if anyone is is looking for some kind of ways to apply Jung more, I tell people to do the
荣格分析师看着人们在海滩上做瑜伽并建立这些联系。像斯通（Stones）这样的人，我们已经在我们的播客上采访过塔玛·斯通（Tamar Stone），哈尔的女儿，还有像阿尼·曼德尔（Arnie Mendel）这样的人，他们做过程导向治疗，如果有人正在寻找一些应用荣格的方法，这是一本非常有趣的书，我告诉人们去做
post Jungians because a lot of people are like, I want to do Jungian therapy. So I'm going to go out and I'm going to buy the black books. And I'm like, I don't know, Tom, that's going to let you do therapy there. I think the people who figured out how to apply this in the room in a more practical way are probably, if you read Embracing Ourselves, probably, you know, if you read, embracing ourselves, the voice dialogue manual, if you breathe, if you read the process oriented therapy stuff, there's more technique there, which Jung is a map. He's not a technique.
后荣格派，因为很多人说，我想做荣格治疗。所以我打算出去买《红书》（Black Books）。我说，我不知道，汤姆，那不会让你在那里做治疗。我认为那些弄清楚如何在房间里以更实际的方式应用这一点的人可能是，如果你读《拥抱我们》（Embracing Ourselves），可能，你知道，如果你读，拥抱我们，语音对话手册，如果你呼吸，如果你读过程导向治疗的东西，那里有更多的技术，荣格是一张地图。他不是一种技术。
You have to infer the techniques from the map. And that's where a lot of people, I think, get confused or frustrated. They want to make him like a series of philosophical suppositions and then try and disprove him. And that isn't how he writes. That's not what he's doing. No, no. If you look at it like that, you're fundamentally missing the point. How do you work with dreams?
你必须从地图中推断出技术。这就是我认为很多人感到困惑或沮丧的地方。他们想让他像一系列哲学假设，然后试图反驳他。这不是他写作的方式。这不是他在做的事情。不，不。如果你那样看它，你从根本上就错过了重点。你如何处理梦？
I mean, in part of that question, I'm just curious if you have deeper thoughts on what dreams are and then maybe, I don't know, clinically if you utilize dreams with certain people. So that's another thing that's probably going to make everybody mad at me if I speak honestly there. Yeah, thank you for the honesty. Well, I think dreams are really relevant some of the time. But if you're doing, and maybe other people are better at it than me,
我的意思是，在那个问题的一部分中，我只是好奇你对梦是什么是否有更深刻的想法，然后也许，我不知道，在临床上你是否与某些人利用梦。所以这是另一件可能会让每个人都对我生气的事情，如果我诚实地说的话。是的，谢谢你的诚实。嗯，我认为梦在某些时候确实是相关的。但如果你正在做，也许其他人比我更擅长，
but if you're trying to do everything with dream work, I don't know if that's the fastest way to get there. Where I think dreams are the most powerful is where somebody is right on the edge of change. They already know something, but they haven't realized that yet. I mean, while I've done therapy with somebody for, some of my patients will laugh at these, but I've done therapy for something with somebody for two or three months, and no dreams were mentioned.
但如果你试图用解梦来做所有事情，我不知道那是否是到达那里的最快方式。我认为梦最强大的地方在于某人正处于改变的边缘。他们已经知道了一些事情，但他们还没有意识到这一点。我的意思是，虽然我和某人做过治疗，我的一些病人会嘲笑这些，但我已经和某人做过两三个月的治疗，没有提到任何梦。
But I'm listening to the content of the day and I'm like, what were your dreams like last night? You have any interesting dreams? They're always like, how did you know? I'd never dream. And I just had the craziest. Yeah. You know, if you look at something like the hero's journey, that Joseph Campbell monomyth, you look, you know, a lot of that is relevant to psychotherapy and we don't do it once and then come back and be Gilgamesh.
但我正在听当天的内容，我说，你昨晚的梦是什么样的？你有什么有趣的梦吗？他们总是说，你怎么知道的？我从不做梦。我刚刚做了最疯狂的。是的。你知道，如果你看看像英雄之旅，那个约瑟夫·坎贝尔（Joseph Campbell）的单质神话，你看，你知道，很多都与心理治疗有关，我们不会做一次然后回来就成为吉尔伽美什（Gilgamesh）。
We do it over and over again with different issues where we want to deflect and make these not real and somehow make them irrelevant. And then slowly have to be like, okay, fine. I'm bad at it. I'm going to go do it. And, and, and when people are at important places on that wheel, that's when you get it. Like I had one, one of the people that I, I don't remember if I'd done brain spotting with him yet, just brain spotting will kick your dreams off. But I think it was before that. And there was someone who had a dream and I, yeah, I was like, you know, he said, initially I can't remember it. And then I said, you know, think about it. I'm not sure if I'm going to be able to do it. I'm not sure if I'm going to be able to do it. but I think it was before that. And there was someone who had a dream and I was like, he said initially I can't remember it and then I said,
我们一遍又一遍地用不同的问题来做，我们想要偏转并使这些不真实，并以某种方式使它们无关紧要。然后慢慢地不得不说，好吧，好吧。我不擅长。我要去做了。而且，当人们在那个轮子的重要位置时，那就是你得到它的时候。就像我有一个，我，我不记得我是否已经对他做过脑点（brain spotting）了，只是脑点会启动你的梦。但我认为是在那之前。有一个人做了一个梦，我，是的，我说，你知道，他说，最初我不记得了。然后我说，你知道，考虑一下。我不确定我是否能做到。我不确定我是否能做到。但我想是在那之前。有一个人做了一个梦，我当时说，他说最初我不记得了，然后我说，
think more about it and I better come back to you because it seems like it's still in your body. You have a different kind of activation when you mention it. And he had remembered a dream that he was in a kind of dark house and that there were three voices like screaming his name and that there were three voices screaming his name, and that he went outside and there were these three women that were different ages and masks with torches yelling at him to go into the dark. I was like, well, what did the mask look like?
多想想它，我最好回到你身边，因为它似乎还在你的身体里。当你提到它时，你有不同种类的激活。他记得一个梦，他身处一所黑暗的房子里，有三个声音在尖叫他的名字，有三个声音在尖叫他的名字，他走到外面，有三个不同年龄和戴着面具的女人拿着火把对他大喊大叫，让他进入黑暗。我说，嗯，面具看起来像什么？
I have a labyrinth on my desk and he was like, had little lines on it but they were curved, but they weren't a spiral, like this, whatever this is. Which if you know anything about the labyrinth on my desk and he was like, oh, it had little lines on it, but they were curved, but they weren't a spiral, kind of like this, whatever this is. Which if you know anything about the labyrinth, that has a whole lot of significance there, which he had never seen one before. But he was like, yeah, it was this shape, it had that in the middle.
我的桌子上有一个迷宫，他说，上面有小线条，但它们是弯曲的，但它们不是螺旋，像这样，无论这是什么。如果你知道关于我桌子上的迷宫的任何事情，他说，哦，它有小线条，但它们是弯曲的，但它们不是螺旋，有点像这样，无论这是什么。如果你知道关于迷宫的任何事情，那在其中有很大的意义，他以前从未见过。但他就像，是的，它是这个形状，中间有那个。
I talked about the Aranese, or there's a lot of things from Celtic mythology too, where there's usually women, but sometimes both genders, but three different ages of people that signify the beginning of a journey, they come and challenge you and say, this is what you're going to do and give you either a prophecy or a challenge or a conflict. He really connected that to a ton of things and said, yeah, that's what's happening.
我谈到了阿拉内斯（Aranese），或者凯尔特神话中也有很多东西，通常是女性，但有时是两种性别，但三个不同年龄的人标志着旅程的开始，他们来挑战你并说，这就是你要做的，并给你一个预言或挑战或冲突。他真的把那与很多事情联系起来，并说，是的，这就是正在发生的事情。
I'm realizing that all the things I thought I was coming into there before, not really what the problem is. The problem is actually much deeper, more horrible, and I'm ready to look at that now. So that's kind of how I work with them, is I wait until I think they're probably active. I mention that if the client has one, I let them go through it emotionally without any analysis.
我意识到我之前认为我进入的所有事情，并不是真正的问题所在。问题实际上要深得多，更可怕，我现在准备好看看那个了。所以这就是我与他们合作的方式，我等到我认为他们可能活跃的时候。如果客户有一个，我提到这一点，我让他们在没有任何分析的情况下在情感上经历它。
And then at the end, I kind of say, these are some universal pieces. How do you think that those might apply to you? And usually that connection is helpful. Amazing. Not the typical way that an analyst would work with dreams, but I'm not a young gay analyst. Right. Yeah. Are there any other theories
然后在最后，我有点说，这些是一些普遍的部分。你认为这些可能如何适用于你？通常这种联系是有帮助的。太棒了。不是分析师处理梦的典型方式，但我不是一个年轻的同性恋分析师。对。是的。还有其他理论
or approaches that are really important to you? Because it seems like you're bringing a lot of these things together. No. I think that I'm probably ADD enough to be so easily bored that I love synthesizing information and then I kind of exhaust people because I don't go at depth with any one thing. I tend to just sort of like really need to understand
或方法对你来说真的很重要吗？因为看起来你正在把很多这些东西放在一起。不。我认为我可能足够多动症（ADD），以至于很容易感到无聊，我喜欢综合信息，然后我有点耗尽人们，因为我没有深入研究任何一件事。我倾向于只是真的需要理解
how a bunch of ideas fit together, what the history of people chewing on those are. And so I mean, a lot of my work, like most psychotherapists is probably populated by a lot of different weird rabbit holes you went down and you collect those techniques and maps and, and ways of knowing as you learn and they become available to you. But I know therapy looks very different for all my patients. It's not like I have one style and sort of adhere to it more flexible than that.
一堆想法是如何结合在一起的，人们咀嚼这些想法的历史是什么。所以我的意思是，我的很多工作，像大多数心理治疗师一样，可能充满了你走过的许多不同的奇怪兔子洞，你收集那些技术和地图，以及当你学习时知道的方式，它们变得对你可用。但我知道治疗对我的所有病人来说看起来非常不同。并不是说我有一种风格并坚持它，比那更灵活。
So. Yeah, I'm the exact same way. I mean, part of that's rooted in my understanding of how the therapeutic Alliance works and just how everyone's so different. Yeah, for sure. For sure. Is, is, is, I mean, I know it's going to be important to you obviously as a therapist, but I'm curious, yeah.
所以。是的，我和你完全一样。我的意思是，这部分植根于我对治疗联盟如何运作的理解，以及每个人是多么不同。是的，当然。当然。是，是，是，我的意思是，我知道这显然对你作为治疗师很重要，但我很好奇，是的。
How do you think about the relationship side of things when you're kind of building that alliance with somebody that really important to you? Is it less, are you more like technique? No, I mean, I think the relationship is super important, but a lot of people say that and I kind of wonder what they mean. Sure. Like to me, I don't need to be, I think it's kind of myopic to have one of those extremely relational lenses where everything that the patient says is about you, and especially some of that neophoridium stuff where they're
当你与某人建立那种对你真正重要的联盟时，你是如何看待关系方面的？是更少，你更像技术吗？不，我的意思是，我认为关系非常重要，但很多人这么说，我有点想知道他们是什么意思。当然。对我来说，我不必是，我认为拥有那些极度关系化的镜头之一是短视的，病人说的每一件事都是关于你的，尤其是那些新弗洛伊德（neophoridium）的东西，他们
like, well, every time you have to realize that you're the parent and they're whatever. I've had therapists where that was a dynamic and I thought of them as a part of my parents or something and I've had therapists where that was not the case. A lot of those people were like, I think sometimes those things are true as a part of my parents or something. And I've had therapists where that was not the case. And a lot of those people were like, so I think sometimes those things are true as a good lens for like anything in psychotherapy. Anytime you think something has to happen or it has to work this way
就像，嗯，每次你都必须意识到你是父母，他们是什么。我有过治疗师，那是一种动态，我把他们当作我父母的一部分，或者其他什么，我有过治疗师，情况并非如此。很多人就像，我认为有时这些事情是真的，作为我父母的一部分，或者其他什么。我有过治疗师，情况并非如此。很多人就像，所以我认为有时这些事情作为心理治疗中任何事情的良好镜头是真实的。任何时候你认为某事必须发生或它必须以这种方式工作
is sort of where you're not being flexible. And so the relationship I think is what it needs to be. There's some people that just wanna quit biting their nails and leave and then there's other people that I think are looking for a psychotherapist to be more of a shaman or a psycho-pomp or a guide or somebody who brings in a whole bunch of information and provides them sort of a philosophical or metaphorical language for the way to see themselves in the world.
是你没有灵活的地方。所以我认为关系是它需要成为的样子。有些人只是想停止咬指甲然后离开，然后还有其他人，我认为他们正在寻找心理治疗师，更多地成为萨满或心理向导或向导或带来大量信息并为他们提供某种哲学或隐喻语言的人，让他们在世界上看待自己。
But to just front load that when somebody doesn't want that or doesn't need it, I think is, is a distraction, you know, in the best case. And I'm just very, very different. You know, I try and meet the need of the person who comes in, but no, like we all used to joke at consultations. Like if any of my patients ever met each other and talked about therapy, they'd be like, you did what? You know, because I have different relationships with them, you know. Yeah, no, I'm the exact same way.
但当某人不需要或不需要它时，仅仅预先加载它，我认为这是一种干扰，你知道，在最好的情况下。我只是非常，非常不同。你知道，我试图满足进来的人的需求，但没有，就像我们过去在咨询时开玩笑一样。如果我的任何病人见过面并谈论治疗，他们会说，你做了什么？你知道，因为我和他们有不同的关系，你知道。是的，不，我和你完全一样。
Have you ever interacted with either on your podcast or read Paul J Leslie? Leslie, the names are familiar, but he writes a lot about like Milton Erickson and kind of has developed his own approach to what he calls like a magical session. He's more like in the strategic side, but also into kind of some of the collaborative kind of postmodern stuff. But anyways, in talking to him quite a bit, he's just underscored, yeah, exactly what you were saying. If a certain client needs a more authoritative approach, that's what I'm going to give him. But if he needs something else, it's going to be the exact opposite. It has to be kind of what the client needs. Yeah, and I think that that is one of the reasons why I'm suspicious of when people have a really strong style over the
你是否曾经在你的播客上与保罗·J·莱斯利（Paul J Leslie）互动过，或者读过他的书？莱斯利，名字很熟悉，但他写了很多关于像米尔顿·埃里克森（Milton Erickson）的东西，并且有点发展了他自己的方法，他称之为像神奇的会议。他更像是在战略方面，但也进入了某种协作式的后现代东西。但无论如何，在和他谈了很多之后，他只是强调了，是的，正是你所说的。如果某个客户需要更权威的方法，那就是我要给他的。但如果他需要别的东西，那将是完全相反的。它必须是客户所需要的。是的，我认为这就是为什么我怀疑当人们在
relationship is because I've seen a lot of people who can only handle one kind of referral. Like, I'm like, yeah, if there's a man that's out of touch with vulnerability, they're going to do great with this person, but I'm not going to send somebody who's already in touch with vulnerability, you know, and isn't threatened by it there because they some like there's a lot of people that can only handle this like one kind of referral of patient and when you start to like need people to go through a certain kind of process, I just think whether you're not making room for everybody, if that makes sense. Yeah. And a lot of so that's kind of why I'm integrative and wear a lot of hats is not everyone's going to think the same way. Not everyone wants to
关系之上有一种非常强烈的风格时，因为我见过很多人只能处理一种转介。就像，我说，是的，如果有一个男人与脆弱感脱节，他们会和这个人相处得很好，但我不会把已经与脆弱感接触的人送去，你知道，并且不会被它威胁，因为他们有些人，你知道，有很多人只能处理这种一种转介的病人，当你开始需要人们经历某种过程时，我只是认为无论你是否没有为每个人留出空间，如果这说得通的话。是的。所以这就是为什么我是综合性的，戴着很多帽子，不是每个人都会以同样的方式思考。不是每个人都想
engage with trauma metaphorically, you know, some people do and some people I think can't. They want to understand what's happening through polyvagal theory or more of a neurobiological lens and that's what's going to be empowering. Sure. Now, okay, maybe as I'm kind of landing the plane a little bit, one question I did want to ask you, going back to kind of Jung, Hillman, and just some of the things that we're seeing in, I don't know how to describe it, just
隐喻性地参与创伤，你知道，有些人这样做，有些人我认为不能。他们想通过多迷走神经理论或更多的神经生物学镜头来理解正在发生的事情，这就是将要赋予力量的东西。当然。现在，好吧，也许当我有点着陆时，我想问你的一个问题，回到荣格、希尔曼，以及我们正在看到的一些事情，我不知道如何描述它，只是
like contemporary masculinity. I mean, I know even in your conversation with Tacey, you talked about how Hillman kind of linked up with Robert Bly and the mythopoetic men's movement. I just kind of wanted to see where you go with that, like what some of your thoughts are on that whole strand of the kind of Jungian approach. Yeah, I think the 80s mythopoetic men's movement probably gets more criticism than it deserves. Like I think it helped a lot of people that had PTSD,
像当代男性气质。我的意思是，我知道即使在你与泰西的谈话中，你也谈到了希尔曼是如何与罗伯特·布莱（Robert Bly）和神话诗意男性运动联系起来的。我只是想看看你对此有何看法，比如你对那种荣格方法的那一脉有什么想法。是的，我认为80年代的神话诗意男性运动可能得到的批评比它应得的要多。就像我认为它帮助了很多患有创伤后应激障碍（PTSD）的人，
a lot of people that were veterans, a lot of people in a non-traditional way. But I also think a lot of things that inspired were not great, that there was a lot of, I mean, I guess some people say toxic masculinity or whatever, but we have a very egoic hero myth, especially in America. I think people who are hurt and don't have any personal power are very likely, especially men, to compensate by feeling superior, feeling better than other people,
很多退伍军人，很多以非传统方式的人。但我也认为它激发的很多事情并不好，有很多，我的意思是，我想有些人说有毒的男性气质之类的，但我们有一个非常自我的英雄神话，尤其是在美国。我认为受伤且没有任何个人力量的人非常有可能，尤其是男人，通过感到优越、感觉比别人好来补偿，
in a way that's not healthy. And so that a lot of times when you get into the world of people cherry picking young, in order to try and appeal to damaged young men, you have to be very careful. And a lot of the people that are on social media right now are not careful, even if they're trying to be. I don't know if that's what you're asking,
以一种不健康的方式。所以很多时候，当你进入人们挑选荣格的世界时，为了试图吸引受损的年轻人，你必须非常小心。现在在社交媒体上的很多人并不小心，即使他们试图这样做。我不知道这是不是你在问的，
but there's definitely a lot of room for danger there. And I mean, look at somebody like the life of Robert Moore, who was a very kind of gentle guy who dedicated his life to the study of consciousness and reflection and his life ends in a murder-suicide. So, I mean, I think that those things are real and that we have to be very careful about how we treat the woundedness of men, of everybody.
但那里肯定有很多危险的空间。我的意思是，看看像罗伯特·摩尔（Robert Moore）的生活，他是一个非常温柔的人，他致力于意识和反思的研究，他的生活以谋杀-自杀结束。所以，我的意思是，我认为这些事情是真实的，我们必须非常小心我们如何对待男人的受伤，每个人的受伤。
And a lot of the stuff I see on social media is not, about half of it I think is outright grift that the person wants to make money and that they know what they're doing is crazy. And then I think the other half of it are wounded healers that are more wounded than healing because they haven't done their own work, you know. Yeah, man. That's, that's powerful.
我在社交媒体上看到的大部分东西都不是，我认为大约有一半是彻头彻尾的诈骗，那个人想赚钱，他们知道他们在做的事情是疯狂的。然后我认为另一半是受伤的治疗者，他们受伤多于治愈，因为他们没有做自己的工作，你知道。是的，伙计。那是，那是强大的。
So any, anything else about you, man, that, that is important to you? Maybe I haven't asked. I know there's, there's tons we could talk about, but is there anything else that has been important to you about that figure that we could almost end on? Well, I think when you look at somebody who really tried to understand themselves over the course of a life, let themselves change over the course of a life, was not afraid of themselves, Jung is a pretty good example. That's a great way to put it, yeah.
所以任何，关于你的任何其他事情，伙计，那，那对你很重要？也许我没有问。我知道有，有吨我们可以谈论，但还有什么对你来说关于那个数字很重要，我们可以几乎结束？嗯，我认为当你看着一个真正试图在生命过程中了解自己，让自己在生命过程中改变，不害怕自己的人时，荣格是一个很好的例子。这是一个很好的表达方式，是的。
And I was listening to Douglas Raskoff's podcast the other day and the guest said something about like, you can't really know if someone has lived and ended themselves until the end of their life. So don't worry about trying to figure out if you're doing it right. Just kind of navigate to what's intuitive and what feels right in a way that is challenging, not in a way that is easy.
我前几天在听道格拉斯·拉斯科夫（Douglas Raskoff）的播客，嘉宾说了一些关于，你不能真正知道某人是否生活并结束了自己，直到他们生命的尽头。所以不要担心试图弄清楚你是否做得对。只是导航到直观的东西和感觉正确的东西，以一种具有挑战性的方式，而不是以一种容易的方式。
And you're probably gonna get there. And I was like, yeah, that's true. Like when I look for biographies, that's the arc. I read a lot of biographies and a ton of the time we're autobiography, you see where somebody's trying to do something. I think Hillman stagnates at a point that he later recovers from, but there's places where people lose the thread. I think Jung is a really good example of checking yourself with being
你可能会到达那里。我当时想，是的，那是真的。就像当我寻找传记时，那是弧线。我读了很多传记，很多时候我们是自传，你看到某人在试图做某事。我认为希尔曼在后来恢复的一点上停滞不前，但有些地方人们失去了线索。我认为荣格是一个很好的例子，用
eternally curious, I think a deep and profound curiosity, and a comfortability with being open to new perspectives. Not to say, you know, we knew nothing, you don't have to be Socrates. But just really being curious. I mean, there's like a Herzogian, you know, curiosity to Jung where we have the conversations that he had with Pauli about, Wolfgang Pauli about math. That was one of the ways into the post-Cycler sacred that he saw, was that sort of quantum physics and really high order math would get to this place where they spoke to the mysterious, where they were no longer objective things,
永恒的好奇心来检查自己，我认为一种深刻而深远的好奇心，以及对开放新视角的舒适感。不是说，你知道，我们什么都不知道，你不必是苏格拉底。但只是真正的好奇。我的意思是，荣格有一种赫尔佐格式（Herzogian）的好奇心，我们有他和泡利（Pauli）关于数学的对话，沃尔夫冈·泡利（Wolfgang Pauli）。那是他看到的通往后世俗神圣的方法之一，即量子物理学和真正的高阶数学会到达这个地方，在那里它们与神秘事物对话，在那里它们不再是客观事物，
that they were more of a, there was some subjectivity there and that's one of the ways he saw. We don't have the conversations he had with Einstein. It would be fascinating to know when he drank a lot of red wine with Einstein what they talked about, and no one ever wrote it down. If he wrote it down, it's not published.
它们更多的是一种，那里有一些主观性，这是他看到的方法之一。我们没有他和爱因斯坦（Einstein）的对话。知道当他和爱因斯坦喝了很多红酒时他们谈论了什么会很迷人，没有人把它写下来。如果他写下来了，它没有出版。
But there's a lot that the family still sits on. One of the guests that- Can you speak to that? Do you know anything about what's still being held on? Well, Jung had a menage a trois, and that's something that even until the past 50 years, I think the family was not super comfortable with the details of. I had a guest who off mic told me that he was in one of the institutes
但家庭仍然坐拥很多东西。其中一位嘉宾——你能谈谈吗？你知道关于仍然被持有的任何事情吗？嗯，荣格有一个三人行（menage a trois），即使在过去50年里，我认为家庭对细节也不是很舒服。我有一位嘉宾在麦克风外告诉我，他在其中一个研究所
and went into one of the family estates and he was sitting on a coffin that was there. And one of the family members said, you know, it's in that coffin. You know, it's the unpublished chapters of Memory, Dreams, Reflections, it's what we took out because we didn't want. We didn't want that to be something that was. So it was about his affair with Tony Wolford. I don't know if affairs the right word you know he had an open relationship that
并进入了其中一个家庭庄园，他坐在那里的一口棺材上。其中一个家庭成员说，你知道，在那口棺材里。你知道，这是《记忆、梦、反思》（Memory, Dreams, Reflections）中未发表的章节，这是我们拿出来的，因为我们不想。我们不想让那成为某种东西。所以那是关于他和托尼·沃尔福德（Tony Wolford）的婚外情。我不知道婚外情是不是正确的词，你知道他有一个开放的关系，
his wife knew about and everyone knew about and it seemed like it didn't cause a problem. I don't know I'm not sure. Was his wife okay with it? I'm only thinking of this is great theologian Carl Bart who had a similar arrangement and the wife wasn't that okay with it but what else was she gonna do at the time? But I'm curious. Do you know how his wife felt about it? I mean that there's a lot of debate about that and I don't I don't know but I think that they continue to work together It wasn't like there you don't sense hostility You know at one point Wolf leaves both leaves when alchemy is something that Ewing's into and she's just like I can't go there
他的妻子知道，每个人都知道，看起来它没有引起问题。我不知道，我不确定。他的妻子对此没问题吗？我只是想到这是伟大的神学家卡尔·巴特（Carl Bart），他有类似的安排，妻子对此不太好，但当时她还能做什么？但我很好奇。你知道他的妻子对此感觉如何吗？我的意思是，关于这一点有很多争论，我不知道，但我认为他们继续一起工作，这不像你感觉不到敌意，你知道，在一点上沃尔夫离开了，当炼金术是荣格进入的东西时，她只是说我不能去那里
I don't want to do this. And Emma Yun continues to work with him when she dies, Carl Yun grieves her and yells, you know, in the tower, the queen is dead. And they had a collaborative relationship. So I mean, there was a lot of creativity. There was a lot of love. Are things like that messy and we're feelings hurt? Probably.
我不想做这个。艾玛·荣格（Emma Yun）在他去世时继续与他工作，卡尔·荣格哀悼她并大喊，你知道，在塔里，女王死了。他们有一种协作关系。所以我的意思是，有很多创造力。有很多爱。像那样的事情是混乱的，感情受到伤害吗？可能。
I don't know, you know, the way that we're supposed to be. And I'm not trying to judge him or excuse anything that was wrong. I don't see anything that's obvious there. It looks like a complicated life. Yeah. No, I'm right there with you. Dude, I feel like your thoughts on curiosity are exactly the kind of person I want to be.
我不知道，你知道，我们应该成为的方式。我不是想评判他或原谅任何错误的事情。我没有看到任何明显的东西。这看起来像是一个复杂的生活。是的。不，我和你在一起。伙计，我觉得你对好奇心的想法正是我想成为的那种人。
And that's a great way to think about Jung. He was the one who was endlessly curious about so many things. Yeah, I think he was bumping up against the limits of knowledge, the limits of the future. And there is sort of a grief at the end of life because you realize how tenuous this thing is and how much we're like always about to be right on the edge of having fucked it up beyond repair. And yes, when he's talking about, you know, I think the future of the world is hanging by a thread looking at the nuclear age coming. I think he was right, I think he's still right, and I think more than that. And doesn't he say that thread is the psyche? I don't know the extent of that quote. I think it was in the BBC interviews at the end of his life. The clip that I've seen, I mean I've watched that whole interview a couple
这是一个思考荣格的好方法。他是那个对这么多事情无尽好奇的人。是的，我认为他正在撞击知识的极限，未来的极限。生命结束时有一种悲伤，因为你意识到这东西是多么脆弱，以及我们总是多么即将处于因为愚蠢的错误而无法修复地搞砸它的边缘。是的，当他在谈论时，你知道，我认为世界的未来悬于一线，看着核时代的到来。我认为他是对的，我认为他仍然是对的，而且我认为不仅仅是那样。他不是说那根线是心灵吗？我不知道那个引用的程度。我想是在他生命结束时的BBC采访中。我看到的片段，我的意思是，我看了整个采访
times and I don't have, you know, all of you uncommitted to memory, but I think he says the future is hanging by a thread and leaves it there. And it was, you know, you look at the amount of times where we almost wiped the world out through a nuclear arsenal just because of a stupid mistake. The light reflected off a satellite and we thought, hey, maybe the USR is going to bomb us. Let's go ahead and wipe them out. Oh, and then somebody was like, let's wait a couple of minutes and just check on this
几次，我没有，你知道，把所有荣格的东西都记在脑子里，但我认为他说未来悬于一线，然后就留在那儿了。而且，你知道，你看看我们因为一个愚蠢的错误而差点通过核武库消灭世界的次数。光从卫星上反射回来，我们想，嘿，也许苏联要轰炸我们。让我们继续消灭他们。哦，然后有人说，让我们等几分钟，检查一下这个
thing. And, you know, we really should maybe take some of that, those places, the metamodern is pointing us to, you know, the sacredness of human life, the sacredness of the planet, the sacredness of, and maybe return some of the mystery of consciousness to psychology. All of those things are not just heady English major woowoo ideas that we should talk about in drum circles. I really would like more of that in government. I really would like more of it in the institutions that teach us psych. And it is very absent. It has been.
而且，你知道，我们真的应该采纳元现代主义所指引我们的那些方向，比如人类生命的神圣性、地球的神圣性，或许还要将意识的神秘感重新引入心理学。所有这些不仅仅是英语专业学生在鼓圈里谈论的那些虚无缥缈的想法。我真的希望政府能更多地体现这些理念，也希望教授心理学的机构能更多地采纳它们。但目前这些理念非常缺失，一直以来都是如此。
Good. Couldn't agree more. Love it. Thank you so much again for your time. This has been great. And yeah, man, keep up the good work. Yeah, thank you That boy needs therapy Psychosomatic That boy needs therapy You need psychosomatic That boy needs therapy You lying down on the couch? What does that mean? I don't expect you to get my perspective Or what you expect from a therapy session AAAAAAAA
很好。我完全同意。太棒了。再次非常感谢你抽出时间。这次谈话非常精彩。伙计，继续保持出色的工作。是的，谢谢你。那男孩需要治疗，身心疾病，那男孩需要治疗，你需要身心治疗，那男孩需要治疗。你躺在沙发上吗？那是什么意思？我不指望你能理解我的观点，或者你对治疗过程有什么期待。啊啊啊啊啊啊啊啊
All you children gather round We will dance and we will whirl We will dance to our own song We must spin to our own world Won't you dance with me? Stop your crying. Dance with me. Feel the rhythm of my arms. Don't let's cry now. Dance with me. And I can see the world's round about to end. All children gather round. We will dance.
所有孩子们围过来，我们将跳舞，我们将旋转，我们将随着自己的歌声起舞，我们必须旋转进入我们自己的世界。你不和我一起跳舞吗？别哭了。和我一起跳舞。感受我双臂的节奏。别哭了。和我一起跳舞。我能看到世界即将终结。所有孩子们围过来。我们将跳舞。
and we would dance together. I'm not a big fan of a lot of the BS and the wellness space. Hardy has randomized controlled trials on all of its products that they paid to be conducted by external researchers who found a lot of validity in what they do. One of the things that I like about Hardy is that they do double blind randomized controlled trials, which is the gold standard of research. And they've shown that on top of a lot of health benefits that mental health is improved and that especially in children with autism and ADHD, mood, anxiety, and symptoms of irritability were reduced
我们会一起跳舞。我不太喜欢健康领域里的很多废话。Hardy对其所有产品都进行了随机对照试验，这些试验由他们付费聘请的外部研究人员进行，他们发现这些产品具有很高的有效性。我喜欢Hardy的一点是，他们进行的是双盲随机对照试验，这是研究的黄金标准。研究表明，除了许多健康益处外，心理健康也得到了改善，特别是在患有自闭症和多动症的儿童中，情绪、焦虑和易怒症状都有所减轻。
which is one of the things that traditional medication doesn't affect and often causes in order to enhance focus. So if you'd go to gethardy.com, that's G-E-T-H-A-R-D-Y.com, and use offer code taproot, you'll get 15% off. There's also lots of information about all the ingredients and how they work on our website, gettherapybirmingham.com. And if you have any questions, feel free to reach out to one of their wellness advisors. Hardy realized that the people who try their product
而这正是传统药物无法改善，甚至往往会引发的问题，尽管它们旨在提高注意力。所以，如果你访问gethardy.com，即G-E-T-H-A-R-D-Y.com，并使用优惠码taproot，你将获得15%的折扣。我们的网站gettherapybirmingham.com上也有关于所有成分及其作用原理的大量信息。如果你有任何问题，请随时联系他们的健康顾问。Hardy意识到，尝试他们产品的人
like myself, that weren't expecting much Realized that it does make a significant difference and they stay on it for the rest of their life Most of the time so if you head to the website you can schedule with a wellness advisor and get a customized plan made With a professional that Hardy pays for for absolutely free. I hope it works for you. And if you have any questions reach out There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
像我一样，起初并没有抱太大期望，但后来发现它确实产生了显著的影响，大多数人此后便会一直使用。所以，如果你访问网站，你可以预约一位健康顾问，并由Hardy全额资助的专业人士为你制定个性化方案，完全免费。希望它对你有用。如果你有任何问题，请随时联系。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。